I'm all for very cleare eyed approaches
to the energy and power these are the
most important sectors of the economy
here in Britain and around the world and
you you mess them up you them up
it's your extreme Peril and yet you
still haven't repealed the fracking ban
and Sun's kind of gone this half step of
saying well we'll go back in the North
Sea okay well go ahead but you know you
have massive resources here on Shore and
I'll just end with this one quick point
an an intriguing book it was written
called The Secret of Sherwood Forest and
maybe you know about this in 1943 a
bunch of Drillers from Oklahoma came to
Britain during the war and they drilled
in Sherwood Forest and with the span of
a year they drilled over 100 Wells and
went from zero production to 3,000
barrels a day in Britain yes in the span
of a year well I mean up until the 1970s
and 80s we were a energy exporting
country right because you found the
North Sea and it was just amazing right
and then it peaked in the 90s and I
think it's been declining ever since I'm
not remembering those numbers exactly
but you you discover the North Sea and
then you just quit yeah well you got to
keep going